[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and we finally have
our first fully official look at the
upcoming Christopher Nolan film Tenet
the teaser was shown in certain cinemas
before Hobson Shore and it's now been
released online and yeah it just looks
like it's gonna be something special
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the trailer and giving my thoughts
on what will happen in the movie
there are potentially heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything about the film or what could
happen in it then I highly suggest that
you turn off now without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for quick
in this video I hope you enjoy it now
let's get into my breakdown of the
tenets teaser trailer okay so the
roughly 40 second long trailer in
classic Nolan's style is as cryptic as
ever and the brief preview almost
presents itself as a puzzle which needs
to be solved this kind of thing has been
present throughout Nolan's films and
there's no doubt that there will be a
lot of cryptic things that will need to
be unearthed whilst watching it the
title tenant is a palindrome which means
that it's the same going forward as it
is backwards and even the design
suggests that this film will focus on
things moving backwards and forwards in
order to go full circle this was pointed
out this morning in my leaked video by
King Fox so huge shout out to them for
that observation the first poster that
was released for the film was a
spiraling clock and it seems like the
film will focus heavily on time and the
manipulation of it the word 10 appears
in it both forwards and backwards and
was also the only number to appear
highlighted in the poster so it seems
like this will be a huge fixation for
the film the trailer itself opens with a
fractured bullet hole against some
bulletproof glass and John David
Washington's character begins to walk
towards it and on screen we see the
words time has come for a new
protagonist from here we see it slightly
repeat the prior shot before advancing
forward now I didn't originally notice
this but a huge thank you to today mangu
who pointed out that on the second shot
the character's eyes are in a slightly
different position to the first one and
this could perhaps suggest that there
are multiple and alternate timeline
I think this massively cements that the
character will be reconstructing how
certain events went down due to his
ability to travel through time and redo
things the trailer reverse is slightly
again to show some seconds of the prior
shot and he once again steps forward and
the words time has come for a new kind
of mission then appear on screen this
repetition of time in both of the texts
solidifies for me that he will be able
to manipulate time as another dimension
and use it to get a full picture of
everything from here Washington gets
close to the bullet and touches it which
is when the music really ramps up with a
sound of a ticking clock in the
background
Nolan's prior film's inception memento
interstellar and Dunkirk all used time
as narrative devices and it's clear that
the Creator has an obsession with it and
how it works
Washington and walks along and we see
three identical bullet holes all
mirroring the first one I believe that
this is in fact the same bullet just
from different times and Washington will
use it similar to how Batman did in the
Dark Knight could discover who fired it
and the location of them we cut to
Washington lying on his back probably
preparing for a mission and then a man
in a gas mask running then Washington's
character fighting a SWAT team and then
being dragged away which is when we cut
to the title which spins into screen
this spinning is of course similar to a
clock and once again we are getting this
message hammered into us we finish with
Washington's character wearing breathing
apparatus and then his face lights up
which ends the trailer I believe that at
this point the character has been
captured and is using the doorways of
time to escape from the situation and
that's the trailer and my thoughts on it
I have heard some people theorize that
this is going to be a sequel to
Inception but honestly I can't really
see it that film though it had time
manipulation in it was solely focused on
dreams and how they operate whereas this
seems to be more fixated on time
Nolan always create his own original
ideas and since his work on The Dark
Knight franchise pretty much every
property has been his own from the
ground up a thing that if it was tied to
inception that this would create a
constraint for the movie and it would
also have to bow to the rules of that
film whilst trying to create its own it
would also Rob inception in some ways as
if time travel was possible then did not
really be any need to dive into other
people's dreams as you could just do
things over and over
until you get them right which would
pretty much make entering their head a
waste of time which actually now I think
of it I guess these guys probably have a
lot of anyway but never mind the film is
being promoted as the most expensive
original film ever made and the emphasis
on this I think will stop it from being
too tied in with Inception as again it
would be easier for Nolan to tell a
unique story rather than to tie this in
to his own past work I may be wrong and
I'm more than happy to hold my hands up
if I am but I think that this will be
its own unique property I'm definitely
excited to see what's gonna come down
the line and I really can't wait to
watch the movie when it's released
obviously I loved hear your thoughts on
this first look and if I missed anything
then make sure you leave it in the
comment section below I'd love to hear
everyone's theories as there's a lot
that can be taken from this tidbit so
make sure you drop them because I'd love
to read them if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my full breakdown of the
ending of Hobbs in Shorewood you'll be
linked at the end the trailer for
Tennant was shown before that film so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books and you can follow
me on twitter at definition whitey it's
the best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this also just want
to let you know that we're currently
giving away a free copy of Avengers end
game on blu-ray to one lucky winner and
all you have to do is like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
Tenet trailer in the comment section
below
the winner will be chosen at random on
August the 10th in the blue row be
shipped out from then - ever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace
you